[Music]
this couple was also on the move Beyonce
and jay-z we have news on where the
Carters and those new twins are living
today the twins haven't actually gone
home to their real home I guess you
could call it where Beyonce and jay-z
live full-time they are in a rented
property in Malibu it's a beautiful
house that kind of overlooks the Pacific
Ocean the idea being that they just
wanted to go somewhere where they could
kind of just spend time focusing on
bonding as a family
the Daily Mail calm is reporting the
beyonce and jay z's twins were born
prematurely but are doing well and are
now at this Malibu mansion known as la
Villa Contenta they were in hospital for
about a week until they were allowed to
leave they are still receiving treatment
and I would imagine that they will
continue to be very closely monitored by
doctors the luxurious property has 14
bathrooms 10 bedrooms and a 25-foot
infinity pool and you may have seen the
estate on the TV show True Blood it's
the home of the vampire queen of
Louisiana less than two hours of Don
it's equipped with anything you could
ever want you know I'm not sure how much
the newborns will be able to take full
advantage of the amenities but the North
Casa family are paying $400,000 a month
in order to stay there we believe that
they will be there until the end of
August should anyone else wish to kind
of snap up the property won't they've
left it is actually on the market for
sale for fifty four point five million
dollars Beyonce's mom Tina was spotted
arriving at the mansion on Sunday she
couldn't wait to see her grandbabies we
have been told that she was actually
present at the birth you know to offer
support to her daughter
[Music]
you